hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're the slow-mo
guys you may have noticed Dan that
whenever we do a video surrounding
Firearms every other comment is that we
should do a video with Kentucky
ballistics pretty much yeah you know
what I refuse yeah I'm just kidding
here's Scott from Kentucky ballistics I
was about to go home they changed their
mind you've become pretty well known for
blowing up guns on your Channel or
getting uh blown up on yeah yeah we've
had a pretty horrendous incident that
almost killed you a little bit of an
oopsie yeah so that's like spawned a
series of videos that you've done yes
and now I've yeah now I've turned that
I've taken uh lemons and turned into
lemonade yes is that the most
understated use of the word oopsie oops
I actually highly recommend checking out
the video that you made where you just
describe everything that happened it's
the one of the gnarliest videos I've
ever seen on YouTube yes I can't believe
I cannot believe you survived I'm I'm
very glad that I did me too yeah so yeah
what we're doing today is we are going
to uh try to get this gun to detonate
I've kind of developed a fascination
with guns blowing up ever since uh my
accident today we have an AR-15 and we
are going to uh load it with a spicy
round something that it's not rated for
upwards of 500 000 PSI and so we're
talking like California Reaper spice
yeah higher than that
it's very spicy high on the Scoville all
right yeah I'm putting rounds on the
Scoville scale just cut away to just
shoving
and just to make sure that we are going
to have an explosion today there is also
a obstruction in that Barrel okay there
is a squib which is a bullet that is
lodged in that barrel and that can
happen sometimes when you're shooting if
you had a round that was undercharged it
doesn't even push the round out of the
barrel which is actually really
dangerous because if you don't know
what's happened and then you fire
another round right behind it
that could be a real life situation that
we cause this to potentially happen
exactly in real life yeah it really
could happen in your life with a Squibb
that's it's happened a lot actually and
that kind of really just shows how
insane your incident was in that there
wasn't even anything in the barrel no
there was no obstruction it was just an
insane round it was it was around that
was uh what we've determined was loaded
with the wrong uh gunpowder wow yeah I
know you've also done some Slimer what's
what speeds do you typically shoot at
I'm kind of ashamed to tell you
well I mean In fairness most of our
stuff is like a thousand I'm filming it
uh about 1400 frames in 2K which for you
guys that's that's nothing so well
especially with this this uh TMX camera
as soon as you said that you're
interested in collab I was like I'm not
going without the without this camera
because this is going to be good this is
what this camera was made for I'm really
curious to see uh what this looks like
because with my slow-mo it's it's still
just happens so fast that you can't
really see what's happening the sound
you hear is a generator powering the
cameras where a thousand frames a second
on the 4K and 82 000 frames a second on
the TMX
well that worked this is uh called a
Kentucky Easter egg hunt
gun parts
Easter was different where we grew up
yeah
it actually blew out through here so you
can see yeah
like where that bullet disintegrated in
there part of that probably had to do
with it being squibbed as well if
there's an obstruction there yeah
because if someone helps some of it out
yeah okay I think that we still would
have had a detonation but uh you came a
long way to do this so we're going to
make sure
bolt face is all deformed God damn it in
the magazine I think has like gone
downwards and then it's smashed to the
bottom of the magazine against this
trigger still works wow
you know what I find really interesting
about this too what's that is I have
detonated this exact same gun before and
the fact that it exploded in the exact
same way again it's pretty cool yeah
that's cool very consistent yeah and
that's all this like kind of gold color
you're seeing that is from the the brass
the actual round just shredding it's
still in there yeah there's probably the
squib and then the bullet behind the
squib and then the cartridge case is
still is still there still crazy will be
somewhere along here and then the
cartridge case is here and the base of
the cartridge case is blown out yep it's
always so interesting when metal just
looks like plastic afterwards yeah it's
just about the speed yeah
all right playing back this is for
proper speed
wow goodness looks the lexan stopped it
from going upwards yeah I told you oh
it's probably just gonna go straight up
do you know the Sheep behind it really
shows you the actual explosion as well
because it like completely yeah
it's always funny to me how sometimes
when something explodes like that some
pieces go over here some pieces go over
here some pieces just sort of go and
stay in the same place and then just
like drop down it's just like these
perfectly equal forces just balancing
out and just staying there and think
about that upper is fairly heavy in it
through at about like 10. it would have
gone further if it had not been stopped
by the plastic yeah
wow oh
wait so so did the magazine blow apart
before it hit it oh it did I thought it
smashed on the I think the pressure just
shot down into the yeah yeah it was like
there was an explosion at the out of the
breach here coming out of the side and
then there was the smoke and then more
Fire coming out down through the
magazine that's crazy yeah let's do that
frame by frame so there we go let's
start see this is the stuff that you
just yeah I see I would never see this
right ever okay so there's a surprise
there and then you could already see it
starting to go down yeah it's leaking
out the bottom of the and then out of
the back that looks amazing it's like
every little crack is complete there's a
massive explosion just going in every
available space inside there just just
trying to escape yeah exactly it finds
all the weak points everywhere and like
yeah oh it's continuing down the
explosions already pretty much happened
and the front of the gun still hasn't
even moving that's still there it's just
still there now it's gonna just start
slowly moving this bit I saved from like
when it goes to the end of the cliff is
like 57 minutes oh my gosh
it's crazy it's pretty unbelievable to
me that you were filming in what 87 000
frames yeah 82 000 yeah and it's still
so fast exactly like that initial moment
like all the stuff of the gun in the air
now
this speed is like way too slow right
because it looks like nothing's moving
the explosion though is still so it's
still so fast and the bullet if a bullet
came out would also be so [__] yeah we
have to do frame by frame for the
explosion but then just like this before
it yeah
you can watch it multiple times and look
out for different stuff like just
following the shock wave across the
sheet oh wow yeah see it's like working
its way up it's like forcing it against
all the bricks but it's like sucking it
up against it now we're going to test a
different we have another sacrifice for
today's video this is a Remington bolt
action rifle chambered in 300 Winchester
magnum so not a small rifle and uh again
we are going to load it with something
spicy and uh see what happens so really
the explosion is going to happen about
here yeah it'll it'll all be right here
and what'll be interesting to see is if
this bolt stays in here or flies
straight out because
I mean it doesn't take much for that to
just come right back at the shooter so
that's really the goal with this is to
see how safe it is
if it went off when you were shooting it
I've Heard lots of stories of guns
losing their bolt and it coming back and
ending up in your face that's why you
put your face when you're aiming right
yeah I mean you're you're right there so
goodbye cheekbones so there's gonna be
more Spice in here because it's a larger
round right so there's gonna be more
more technically yeah more spice yes you
get more powder in that put more chili
okay yeah more more chili in there yeah
okay
all right
honestly I wasn't expecting it to be
that big
there's a piece oh holy smoke so wait it
didn't blow the boat out
that's the whole Bowl it blew the actual
gun the physical gun apart yeah and the
sport stayed wow wow that's really cool
that's unexpected have you ever all
shredded though look at that it sheered
the lugs off of it wow and have you
blown one of these before yeah yeah
um but that that wasn't the same that
may have been a slightly spicier
meatball than before yeah uh you put too
much chili in it here's a piece of the
mag
um here's the four end
where's the barrel that's what I'm
wondering um oh there it is it's like 20
feet away I thought I saw it stuck in
your camera
[Laughter]
um wow
no it's still well it didn't come out oh
man it pushed it further down so this is
the cartridge still in the in the
cartridge the cartridge is still there
can you see and it's done the same thing
where it's blown the back of this that's
about 20
feet 25 feet away from the table that
one seemed to go into tinier pieces yeah
just looks like a tiny gun now this
looks like a little pistol
that's like the stuff that broke off
part of the lug that's one of the
toughest Parts like the hardest bits of
metal right and yeah
the bolt that's what's taking all the
force yeah that's the bit that's
designed to do that that's another piece
of it oh that's the bottom of the thread
yeah yeah oh yeah that's the underside I
think is it oh my gosh that is embedded
wow that was so in there deep that piece
of plastic what frame rate me out here
one thousand one thousand
oh we're not gonna see nothing
playing back oh what hang on look at the
size of that explosion
something went out the end what what was
that oh it's just gas is that just gas
could it have been like just dirt like
dust or something I wouldn't say that
was like oil
but but it doesn't make sense because
the there's nothing came out there's
there's still a barrel and there's still
a bullet in the barrel maybe there was
just a very tiny Gap that allowed some
gas that would make sense it looks like
a little squirt gun does it yeah
so many pieces it's messed up that was
violent
so this is 187 000 frames a second oh my
God we're slowing down every second of
real time to about two hours
so we should see something here we
should see something yeah
yeah
oh wow
wow that was a legit that was a legit
explosion look at that it's like
different it's still going well yeah
yeah
see the pieces of the gun in the
fireball
wow
that still is
that's such a literal campfire going on
you could have roasted marshmallows over
there okay that's I feel like that's got
to be some sort of Gun oil
is it just like evaporated oil what is
that let's come on the end
I love that that's the the liquid has
come out the end of the gun faster than
the barrel isn't even started moving yet
yeah and that's been directly hit by the
explosion and the square is still in
there the barrel is still just sort of
there but
it's just floating yeah the rest of it's
just gone that's a floating Barrel
when it's sped up a little you can
almost see like a place
yeah that happens again that's a really
awesome sound effects
I don't find that it's somewhere
I'm gonna start using you for my sound
effects for my videos yeah just send me
send me clips I'm gonna get on the mic
yeah I want to hire you for that yeah
there was like green in there as well
you know that thing where uh they say oh
I want you to dismantle that rifle in 30
seconds how about 0.02 seconds
the only problem here would be
reassembling it ah I can disassemble one
really fast yeah that was incredible
footage I've never seen
I've never seen a gun blow up that slow
yeah that was really cool
um it gives me a greater appreciation
for blowing them up like that because
like I don't get to see every little
detail like that like that's crazy and
when you see the fireball that's like
this big it's just so much potential
energy in such a small amount of space
it just makes that metal just flow yeah
with that much energy
so I feel like uh
you're going to want to use this camera
again one day do you think yeah yeah if
uh if you guys will come out again I'd
love to have you out again that's really
cool or I need to I would make a trip to
you yeah yeah come come over to Austin
yeah absolutely no uh I've got a lot of
stuff now that I'm thinking like man we
could do this we could do that there's
yeah it's just like seeing into that
next level of speed yeah it is
unbelievable that camera
again I'm gonna go home just throw away
one anymore just
well hopefully you enjoyed that video
make sure you subscribe to
kentuckyballistics there's a link on the
screen and us as well if you want um
Danity closing thoughts I just want to
thank you for letting us blow up some
guns really yeah I really appreciate it
absolutely yeah thank you you're welcome
anytime thanks so much time and I'll
have your bill uh yeah yeah I'll invoice
you I'll forward it today